YURI GRINSHTEYN: Stackdriver
improves the observability
of our services,
and it helps us put
SRE principles into practice.
But how can you try
some of these features
without impacting your
production monitoring setup?
With the Stackdriver
Sandbox, you
have a fully-instrumented
environment
ready to test in minutes.
I'll show you how to
set it up right now.
This is "The Stack Doctor."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The Stackdriver Sandbox
is an open source project
that helps you learn
how to use Stackdriver.
It includes everything
you need to get started.
It provisions a demo
application composed
of multiple microservices
and configures monitoring.
You can try the project
by visiting its home page
at stackdriver-sandbox.dev
and the associated GitHub
repository.
We'll put links to both
in the description below.
I'm here to show you how to
create a sandbox of your own
and use it to try
Stackdriver features we've
covered in previous episodes.
Start by going to
the Sandbox homepage.
From here, simply click on
the Open in Cloud Shell button
to open Cloud Shell and
download the project repository.
Run the install script
in the current directory.
The script will take a few
minutes to build and deploy
all of the components.
While it's running, let's
review what's happening.
The script is creating a
new Google Cloud project.
Within that project, it's
creating a Kubernetes Engine
cluster and deploying the
sample application to it.
Finally, it's creating a
Compute Engine virtual machine
that'll be used to generate
load against your application.
When the script
finishes running,
it provides you with
four URLs to access.
The first takes you to
the Stackdriver interface
where you go through the process
of setting up your workspace.
You'll need to confirm the
creation of a workspace
and add any other
projects you may
have to be monitored as well.
Once the setup is done, you'll
be ready to use Stackdriver.
The second URL takes you to
the Cloud Console for you
in your project,
and the third URL
takes you to the home page
for your sample application
running in Kubernetes Engine.
The fourth URL takes you to
the load generation tool.
Use it to simulate 20 users
with a hatch rate of two, which
means that two users will
be added every few seconds
until we get up to the full 20.
Now that your application
is under load,
you can use Stackdriver
to observe it.
Start by viewing the
Kubernetes cluster
by selecting Kubernetes
Engine from the Resources menu
in the Cloud Console.
You can use this
dashboard to see
the performance of your
infrastructure, workloads,
and services, and you can click
on each row in the dashboard
to get metrics and
logs for that resource.
Because this is a distributed
application composed
of multiple microservices,
understanding service
latency is key.
Click on Trace on the left side
and then go to the trace list
to see the request being traced.
Then click on a request
to see how it traverses
the services in the application
and latency for each service
call.
Finally, to understand the
performance and resource
utilization of your services
themselves, go to a Profiler.
Select the product catalog
service and CPU time
as the metric.
Profiler shows CPU utilization
down to the method level,
and you can use this data
to optimize both service
performance and
resource utilization.
We've built the Stackdriver
Sandbox to give you
an opportunity to try these
and other Stackdriver features
quickly and easily.
We'll come back to
it in future episodes
and use it to learn about
features like Error Reporting
and Debugger.
Thank you for joining me today,
and come back soon for more.
This is the Stack Doctor.
Stay healthy out there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]